wander franco back like you mentioned
wayne that's going to be a big part of
it because he's got that 39 game on bay
street going right now and hopefully he
can continue that
the tampa bay rays here tonight it's
gonna be right-hander david robertson
making the open for the first time in
his career and nine games on the season
with the rays he's worked eight innings
big strikeout numbers 13 to to go up
against just three walks and they're not
afraid to run oh now they have it picked
off rojas caught napping over there in
the rundown
and robertson
tries to get the tag and he gets out of
the baseline called out yes he did i
mean right there he's kicking off the
the bag and he got caught peeking he
peeked back at g-man choi just as
robertson made his move he never saw it
coming you very rarely see that when
these guys get off the bag
did he go yes he did
tried to check de la cruz out of there
and he is not happy already
fairly demonstrative about that call
brian de la cruz was called out for
swinging at this pitch holly and then he
ended up getting tossed well you can
clearly see the frustration de la cruz
checked his swing the question is did he
go or not now he's going to give you a
different answer than really anybody
else but the first base umpire says he
did and that's what ignites de la cruz
he's on his way down to first base and
he doesn't like it but he's not actually
ejected by the first base umpire he's
ejected by the home plate umpire and i
don't agree with this
sixth major league start for cabrera
coming off a start against the pirates
where he dealt with constant traffic but
he did
notch a new career high in seven
strikeouts
top to bottom pretty good
there's a strikeout right there a cold
strike three right there on the inside
corner
and here's nelson cruz with troy at
first
ground ball that's going to go through
the hole
makes it into left joy heads to second
on the base hit by cruz
3-2
and that's
ball four
because it skips away randy rosarina
will bat with the bases
loaded and a liner in the left toward
the corner
here comes john
cruz will score they're going to sing
meadows the rose arena into second a
double and it's three nothing tampa back
well this right here that was a change
on boy he threw that change up hard and
the rosarina was all over it
i think feeling probably pretty good
after getting that strike two he hammers
one again
and a rose arena the helmet did come off
before he rounded first too
so we still have no evidence of him ever
making a round of a bag with the helmet
on
and it's the fastball that wendell
chased
but a rosarina down into the left field
corner of bases clearing doubles the
scoreless hitting from david robertson
the ray's offense able to put up a quick
three runs
they lead in heading into the second
inning ryan yarbrough now comes on for
the raise and that bolt roll
a wave and a miss
diaz is out on strikes and everything
was all out of sorts
that foot gets down too early and now
you're reaching you're all armed seven
men hitting the first inning for the
raise they scored three times lead three
nothing he gets the strikeout of lao
always a tough one and that's his third
strikeout
02 to choi
and a called strike three got the call
maybe a little north of the zone
but cabrera could use that now cruise
meadows and roaster rain will get a
second crack at him here in inning
number three
but it will not happen here another
strikeout for
cabrera make it five
well every season we've had now cabrera
comes back and gets a rosarena who put
all three of the raised runs on the
board strikes him out on three pitches
they raised three runs two hits no
errors and three left miami no runs one
hit no errors one left and only two noun
visit left
and he's reaching for that one nice job
on the change to get him to chase
bottom of the fourth coming sean guthrie
is on the pitch this will be his 13th
game gonna face the bottom third of the
raise order joey wendell francisco mejia
and kevin kiermeier
well there's joey wendell putting this
one down against the lefty and a high
throw to first he had beaten it out
anyway but you're dead in it
the breaking ball here and joey wendell
staying on it staying on it
and then literally just laying that down
deadening the ball
that's a thing of beauty so the bunt
base head leadoff man to board
ground ball left side that's going to be
a base hit off the glove of alvarez
it will be second and third here's
kiermeier here's with a chance to add to
the lead
high down the left side and that's going
to drop is it fair
yes and against that low wall
wendell scores here comes mejia boy the
breaking ball foot comes down there's
the sweeping swing and the ball popped
up right down the line and there is
nobody there to make a play
a couple of feet
fair raise five the marlins nothing and
with two one and two out in the fifth
francisco mejia
that's aligner in the center for a base
hit
meadows scores
wendell crosses the plate on the base
head by mejia
they give themselves opportunity tonight
they've been cashing them in up and down
the lineup mejia
just swats that ball out into center
here is jazz chisholm with two out
nobody on
and he's strikes out chisholm got him
swinging and we go to the bottom of
hitting six seven nothing raised franco
tonight with a strikeout fly ball to
left and he fouls
to first in the fourth inning
and ball four he walked
and franco heads to first base to keep
that streak going
extends it to 40 consecutive games in
which he has reached base through his
kevin kiermeier kk
he's also reached base
all three times
there's a shot off the bat of kiermeier
in into center that's going to drop and
bounce over the head of sierra
then it's going to allow rosarina to
come around and score and kirby is going
to go to third
standing up
he was completely fooled
and he thinks it's going to be over his
head and then realizes no no no this
thing's falling in
and then over his head to make it
[Music]
it's worse triple and a run batted in
for kiermeier
even keermeyer didn't think that that
ball
was he knew he did not hit it well
it was just
the big swing in the trajectory full
sierra last chance for the marlins one
this evening is jazz
chisholm he is old for three pop to
second flight to center struck out
swinging and that popper
short left should do it
that's wendell over there to make the
grab and the razor winners tonight
one two three in the ninth inning
and the rays have defeated miami
it's an eight nothing ball game
811-0 for the raise nine left 0-2-0
with two left
for miami yarbrough will get the win
he's nine and six cabrera the loser oh
in three
two hours
59 minutes the time of this game
and the rays win their 95th